you've seen a scan of your brain haven't
you yeah and there's quite a bit missing
emilia clarke reveals she's missing
parts of her brain after suffering two
aneurysms the game of thrones actress
opens up to bbc's sunday morning and
recalls overcoming her health scare i
had a couple of brain images and that
kind of
you know you gain a lot of perspective
and it
puts your head in a different place when
dealing with the kind of juggernaut of
being on a successful show
and get this amelia says her character
daenerys targaryen helped her like a
true khaleesi while she was recovering
trying to regain consciousness trying to
stay
i kept asking myself all these questions
i hilariously kept saying lines from the
show in my head i was born to rule the
seven kingdoms and i will emilia also
explains the physical impact of
suffering from multiple brain aneurysms
the amount of my brain that is no longer
usable
it's
remarkable that i am able to
speak sometimes articulately
and live my life completely normally
with absolutely no repercussions it is i
am in the
really really really small minority of
people that can survive that and though
she's laughing she makes quite a serious
reveal you've seen a scan of your brain
haven't you yeah and there's quite a bit
missing literally really yeah it always
makes me laugh
um yes yeah
because strokes basically as soon as as
soon as you're
as soon as any part of your brain
doesn't get blood for
a second
it's gone the starfire shared her near
fatal health condition in march 2019. in
an article the actress wrote for the new
yorker she announced her first aneurysm
happened after wrapping season one of
game of thrones the second aneurysm
happened after shooting season three and
the recovery wasn't as easy as the first
recalling that she looked as though i
had been through a war more gruesome
than any that daenerys experienced
emilia was convinced that she wasn't
going to live but thankfully she made it
out the other side stronger telling e.t
just one month after pending her story
why it was important to share publicly i
just want to help people i want to make
them feel not alone because they're not
the only ones who have experienced
something like that and i and i felt
like i had an opportunity to do that so
it seemed like the only thing to do and
while the whole world was cheering for
emilia amid her recovery perhaps her
biggest cheerleader is jason momoa who
famously started opposite emilia on the
hbo series as her husband khal drogo i
just think it's beautiful that she's
gonna
i mean
she's so brave and then helping the
world and trying to raise awareness
um
i mean
very sad because we almost lost her
numerous times so um
i love her to bits and she's here and
she's going to do great things with it
and teach the world
[Music]
you